you see this bike
see this kiosk and this payment device
all these electronics are run by this
little guy Google's Android operating
system and it's the most popular one out
there controlling roughly two-thirds of
the mobile market Google says it runs on
more than 3 billion devices around the
world that's nearly double the number of
cars globally but that number doesn't
include the wide range of other gadgets
running hidden Android code so how did
it become so popular and why
Android is open source which means it's
free to access
and because the code is all public there
are a ton of developers familiar with it
Google says open source encourages
Innovation which is why the code is and
has been free since the first Android
smartphone in 2008. its competitors
mostly ran proprietary code which meant
nobody other than them could freely use
it Android is highly customizable so
developers can tweak the code to pair
well with a wide variety of devices like
this VR headset and this ATM
it can run efficiently on less expensive
computer parts which makes it cheaper to
scale for example when NASA set out to
make a cost efficient low Earth
satellite it tapped Android's code the
software enabled the satellite to send
photos back to Earth and it's user
friendly this may sound primitive today
but once upon a time phones required
more buttons to use there weren't any
mainstream open source software options
that let you swipe tap and select
objects using your finger that was until
Android this is why it became so popular
and why device makers today use it on a
wide range of touchscreen gadgets okay
so it's open source but how does Google
benefit from all of this because the
Android open source project lets anyone
tinker and learn a lot of developers
become familiar with the software so
when Google is looking to hire
developers it has a richer pool to
choose from then there's the monetary
benefit While most of Google's profit
comes from ads company is often want
access to Google's other software like G
suite and the Play Store Google also
makes money by taking a 15 cut from
subscription apps on the Play Store and
even when a device isn't using those
Google products the company benefits
Google's motto is Android everywhere and
by making the code accessible it can do
just that it wants to become ubiquitous
which is good for brand familiarity
it can still be hard sometimes to know
from the outside when a device is
running Android code and that's because
Google's branding policies can prevent
companies from including the Android
logo on the hardware packaging and
marketing materials even if they use the
code and it makes sense for Google to
limit who can call themselves Android
when the company wants to be known for
Android
still there are some downsides to having
an open OS cyber security experts say
that Androids are a greater Target for
malware and viruses partly because the
Play Store lets third-party software
control a lot more features on a device
compared to Apple's lockdown operating
system there could also be hidden costs
just because you're not paying anything
up front doesn't mean you won't pay
later for access to more core features I
spoke to a computer science professor at
Carnegie Mellon he says that Android has
played a pivotal role in advancing
software mostly because it's open source
which means just by existing Android
helps to push things further especially
when it comes to stuff with a touch
screen so when you see one in the wild
chances are it's probably an Android
[Music]